مع فتاه سجلت اسمها في موسوعه جنس تمارس
واحده من اخطر الاستعراضات ساره الرقباني
هي الرياضيه الاولى في تونس التي تمارس
عروض الهانك هذا العرض
يقدم او يقدم في السيرك ويعتمد على تعليق
كامل الجسم من الشعر مع القيام بحركات
بهلوانيه رشيقه
السلعه على عده ميداليات هي ضيفتنا اليوم
في صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
تعرف على ساره وعبدال خطير من تونس مع
مراسله صباح العربيه احلام العبدلي احلام
اهلا بك اهلا بصاره
اهلا اهلا بكم جميعا نحن امام في الحقيقه
طفله معجزه او شيبه معجزه لنقل ادخلت
موسوعه غينيس بطل في التكواندو تمارس
رياضه خطيره جدا في السيرك تتطلب مؤهلات
بدنيه وذهنيه عاليه وعاليه جدا وكذلك تاكل
النار هذا الشيء الذي اكتشفته انا منذ
قليل بانها تؤدي عروض تاكل خلال هذا
العروض كورات من اللهب ومن النار ساره
الركباني تنضم الينا مباشره لنسالها اول
سؤال الالم ساره مرحبا بك في صباح العربيه
كيف تقاومين الالم الذي تشعرين به وانت
معلقه من شعرك اثناء العروض
والالم تدريجيا همم لن يخف همم لانه همم
هناك نوع من كومبليت من التركيز من
التركيز ومن همم نوع من تحويل الطاقه
والقيام باشياء
او خيال خاص وفي عالم خاص للتناسي او
نسيان
الوجع ومحاوله التركيز في في عالمك الخاص
مع الموسيقى التيتا تضعينها في اثناء
العرض لل معلومه فان ساره الركبان قامت
باتباع كل هذه الانشطه منها الهره واكل
النار وغيرها من خلال تدرب ذاتي بحث تعتبر
الفتاه الوحيده تقريبا في العالم العربي
وحتى في القاره الافريقيه تقول ساره تمارس
هذه الرياضه الخطيره جدا التي عرفت بها
شعوب اخرى في اسيا او في اوروبا او في
مناطق اخرى من العالم تعلمت كل هذا بصفه
ذاتيه همم بعض الفيديوهات
الاجتماعي
الدخول في انشطه خطيره بصفه ذاتيه بدون
تاثير هو صراحه حتى همم بنات هذه الثقه في
نفسي وحتى شجعت نفسي لاقوم بهذه
الاشياء ااااه
بحثت جيدا وشفته كيف تكون المراحل تدريجيا
حتى اقوم بها وانواتي قبل نفسي فمثلا جهزت
نفسي بدنيا ونفيا واحطوا نفسي
طبيه كي اقوم بهذه
العروض الخطيره من دون ان واجهه همم
تاثيرات سلبيه
للمشاهدين فانا ساره الركباني بعض
المعلومات التي اسقيتها تقوم باتباع حميه
خاصه كذلك نظام عنايه خاص بالشاعر يتطلب
مثلا ان يكون شعرها املس على الدوام اي اي
محرومه من بعد التسريحات ممنوع عن همم
تكتسب وزن اكثر او ان اا تنزل عن وزن معين
كذلك ممنوع ان تخسر بعض الفيتامينات من
جسدها لان هذا يشكل همم مخاطر عليها وعلى
ممارستها هذه الرياضه تقبل المجتمع ساره
تقبل العائله والمحيط ممارساتك لهكذا
ريالات خطيره مثل الهر هانك واكل النار
وبعض الاستعراضات الخطيره خاصه البدايه
كانت صعبه ولحد الان كان مازالت صعبه لانه
تقبل كان صعبا صعب كثيرا همم
حاولت وانا احاول نسيت احاول نقطه اقنع
المجتمع انه هذا عرض من السيرك وليس
انتحار هذا العرس سوف تقدمه لناس ساره
الركباني الان سوف تقوم لنا بالحركه التي
دخلت همم بها موسوعه جينيس على المباشره
الان على سباحه العربيه ايتها البطله
متابعه معكم
[موسيقى]
يعني هذه تتطلب لياقه بدنيه
يعني هذه تتطلب لياقه بدنيه قوه
بالحركات الاحمائيه الان في الطريق يعني
حقيقه ان الرشيقه هي مكسب والرياضه تبقى
دائما من اجمل الاشياء في العالم لو رايتم
سعره كيف تقوم بالحركه الاحمائيه في
الشارع امام الماره في الطريق بكل بساطه
واا بكل يعني عفويه وبكل حرفيه وتميز ساره
تحلم بالعالميه وتحلم ان تقدم عروض على
مسارح في كوبرا العواصم في العالم
وبالفعل صار امتعدتنا بالعرض امتعتنا
بالمعلومات عنها واحلام احنا بنشكرك دايما
انه دايما من فيقك من احلامك على البكير
لانه كثير بكير الساعه في تونس وزي ما
انتم شايفين يعني عتمه لسه اليوم انا ساره
انا ساره الجميله
كمان شكرا جزيلا احلام عبد الله